toi
je suis chaud
une baie
Non
je m'appelle Daniel Lugo et je veux
faire du monde un meilleur endroit tout cela a
commencé parce qu'il était temps de me pousser
plus fort là tu vas sinon je
regardais encore 40 ans quand j'ai un
pantalon de survêtement pour  travail, j'ai un plan pour changer
cela où avez-vous passé votre temps pop up
nord comment vous avez trouvé un emploi maintenant vous
ne pouvez tout simplement pas kidnapper un gars et prendre son
truc qui est tellement illégal bien sûr que nous pouvons
Victor Kershaw est un connard criminel qui
mérite que de mauvaises choses lui arrivent nous
traversons cela personne ne se blesse bien
oh mec nous arrachons
nous m'avons attrapé en plus de quelques signatures
merci mon pote donne lui un shake protéiné
tu ne sais même pas ce qui s'est passé j'ai
regardé beaucoup de films Paul I  sais ce
que je fais ces gars ont réussi à
acquérir tous les atouts que vous aviez et ils
apprécient ce qui se passe maintenant maintenant je vais
travailler faire quelque chose de mal peut-être un peu
cela ne se produit pas
Oh